[Musique]
dans l'actualité de ce 5 avril après
versailles direction la région mantaise
les résidences yvelines essonne ont
déménagé leur siège le bailleur social
propose dans le nord du département onze
mille logements sur les 33 mille hlm de
son patrimoine immobilier
un procès historique il ya peu de 75 ans
se tenait le procès de nuremberg lors
duquel des criminels nazis ont dû
répondre de leurs actes devant la
justice
des étudiants des ufr de santé de droit
de l'université versailles saint quentin
ont joué la reconstitution du jugement
de l'un des médecins la remise de prix
du concours villes et villages fleuris a
eu lieu en mars dans les yvelines de
communes obtiennent le label pour la
première fois - ville de gaillard et
réseaux elles font désormais partie des
68 communes distinguer
[Musique]
30% du parc immobilier des résidences
yvelines essonne se situe en val de
seine onze mille logements ils sont
proposés c'est l'une des raisons qui a
poussé le bailleur social a déplacé son
siège de versailles à mantes la jolie le
nouveau site a été inauguré samedi 2
avril dernier
c'est symbolique aussi de l'ambition que
l'on a en matière de construction de hlm
pour nous la chaînette c'est une bonne
chose et donc on veut le prouver ce
siège en est le symbole l'on veut faire
de la qualité on veut faire du beau on
veut faire de l'enviro faire de la
fierté
[Musique]
les accusés dans cette affaire
sont accusés de meurtres tortures
et autres atrocités commis au nom de la
science médicale l'un de ses médecins
jugés au procès de nuremberg s'appelle
wilhelm buybox accusé de crimes de
guerre et de crimes contre l'humanité en
lien avec des expériences médicales
c'est le principal protagoniste de la
reconstitution joué par des étudiants et
des facultés de santé et de droit de
l'université versailles saint quentin un
travail de plusieurs mois tout ce texte
elle convient de lire et de représenter
était à l'origine en allemand et donc il
ya d'abord eu un travail de badauds
recherche de documentation de traduction
parce qu'on était à des milliers de
pages qui a été réduit aussi ses suivis
tout ce qui était vraiment le travail
théâtral au fur et à mesure au fur et à
mesure pendant des répétitions donc
maintenant qu'on s'était bien approprié
le sens de tout essayer de bien
retranscrire ça au public dans le public
l'ancien ministre de la santé agnès
buzyn pour elle la question du
consentement aux expériences médicales
est au coeur de ce procès un
questionnement à l'origine du code de
nuremberg véritable acte de naissance de
la bioéthique les questions d'éthique
reste au coeur de la relation médecin
malade
la question du consentement
et ton toujours en état de donner un
consentement et il éclairé quel est
l'état de vulnérabilité des jo c'est la
grande question qui est posée ce médecin
bagel bagel bloc et a été responsable de
ses actes même s'il ya eu un ordre et
donc tous nos étudiants qui seront de
futurs professionnels quelle sera leur
responsabilité en tant que professionnel
on souhaite donner à nos étudiants jurés
futurs juristes avocats magistrats
médecins infirmiers sages femmes des
clés pour comprendre le monde
contemporain appartient de l'histoire
buck
coupable de crimes de guerre et de
crimes contre une verte finalement
wilhelm buybox sera condamné à 15 ans de
prison après cette reconstitution du
procès au sénat la soirée s'est
poursuivie avec un débat sur le
consentement aux soins
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les mains dans la terre pour planter des
graines ou pour couper des vieux radis
afin de créer du compost les enfants de
l'école maternelle des bestiaires sont
motivés on peut pas la manger parce que
la glâne qu'est ce qu'on va faire après
en fait
les grandes sections avaient rendez vous
au magasin débats et des de maurepas
pour un atelier sur le compostage et le
jardinage moi je m'occupe plus de la
partie potager donc non là on va
vraiment être sur la préparation du
terrain
quelques plantations va vraiment essayer
de leur expliquer un peu touché
uniquement contre au courant de la
saison
préparez les bacs nourrir le sol tout ce
qui est autour un peu de la production
de légumes moi de mon côté je vais leur
présenter le compostage de surface est
également leur montrer comment on peut
réduire ses déchets avec le magasin
grand marché vrac en important des
bocaux et en se servant soi même
l'objectif transmettre des gestes
éco-responsables aux enfants et les
sensibiliser à l'environnement tant
d'escaladé
ils sont des vrais vecteurs
d'information auprès de leurs parents
donc comme le compostage ça va être
obligatoire fin 2023 on va être obligé
de trier ces biodéchets donc en passant
par eux les parents les écouter et ça
leur donne envie de tester le compostage
donc les enfants sont très investis et
mettre les mains dans la terre ça marche
toujours pour un enfant de 5 ans et si
en plus ça peut lui permettre de prendre
déjà des bonnes habitudes de citoyen
nous en tant qu'enseignants pour nous
c'est une très belle opportunité puis
c'est au tour de l'école de reproduire
les mêmes gestes dans la cour de récré
lundi 4 avril il utilisait pour la
première fois leur propre compost pour
planter des radis
ce match
toutes ces actions s'inscrivent dans la
volonté d'obtenir le label de 3 des
écoles en démarche de développement
durable en fait on doit rédiger un
document qui répertorie toutes les
actions passées en cours et futurs au
sein de l'école dans diverses domaine en
lien avec les os des délais dit cet
objectif de développement durable qui
sont des objectifs internationaux
décernés par l'éducation nationale le
label devrait être décerné d'ici la fin
de l'année scolaire il permet de
récompenser les établissements dans leur
engagement pour l'environnement outre le
projet de composteurs et de jardins
potagers la maternelle a mis en place
des actions pour trier ses déchets ou
pour recycler ses fournitures scolaires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la paix qu'une fois
il a trois ans j'ai du bon
petit chou est un petit patient un peu
étrange il fait partie des nombreuses
peluches aux maladies imaginaires venus
accompagnés de leurs amis de jeunes
enfants de 5 ans ils ont pu profiter
d'une consultation gratuite
[Musique]
ils arrivent ils nous disent le nom de
leurs doudous leur âge leur taille etc
on prend les constantes on l'est pèse on
leur demande quelle maladie sont d'après
du coup on voit pouvoir les emmener au
bloc opératoire où ils vont pouvoir pas
s'habiller un peu comme les vrais sur un
chien puis on va alors leur montrer
d'esserent qu'on peut faire pour sauver
le doubs et puis pouvez aussi aller à la
radio après on les amène à la pharmacie
donc là on a fabriqué des petits
médicaments d'efforts pour que puissent
vraiment prendre conscience de ce que
c'est un médicament la salle du vieux
marché à jouy en josas a pris le temps
d'une journée la lure d'un hôpital pour
nounours une quinzaine d'élèves en
deuxième année de médecine à
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines organise ces cessions dans
plusieurs villes des yvelines chaque
année une façon pour les enfants de
découvrir le monde médical une autre
façon on va endormir doudou comme ça il
aura pas mal pendant qu'on va réparer
son bras d'accord si justement pour les
sensibiliser déjà au milieu médical pour
qu'ils aient moins peur pour que quant à
eux ils seront amenés à l'échelle
médecin il ait confiance que ce qu'en
général les enfants qui sont un petit
peu free et surtout par les blouses
blanches parce qu'ils connaissent pas
trop mais là le fait de les avoir vus en
amont avec leur doudou ça leur fera
moins perquisitions à l'hôpital où je
même chez le médecin généraliste et pour
les étudiants de se former à communiquer
avec les plus petits mois déjà
j'aimerais de pédiatres ça nous apporte
déjà le fait de pouvoir avoir un premier
contact avec les enfants c'est vrai que
en stage on a moins de sage de pédiatrie
autres on va souvent l'adulte est pour
sa part bien d'avoir un peu une approche
et des enfants parce que c'est pas la
même chose ils comprennent pas pareil il
faut agir différemment et entre les
différents mots attribués aux peluches
par les enfants une thématique semble
revenir plus que les autres
il a commis dans musique au courant
navires et ça ils avaient ils ont tous
approuvé d'épidémie en fait mais que
personne ne s'inquiète tout lé nounours
ont été soignés à la fin les enfants se
sont vus chacun attribuer un diplôme de
nounoursologues pour en témoigner un
suivi des patients se fera ensuite dans
leur classe avec leurs professeurs
[Musique]
déjà vous avez la gare qui a une minute
à pied et elle vous mène directement à
montparnasse en 25 minutes on a juste à
côté les écoles de la maternelle
jusqu'au lycée tout se fait soit à pied
soit en bus et on a une boulangerie elle
est excellente c'est parti je vous
emmène c'est une agence immobilière pas
comme les autres lagence de villepreux
utilisent un moyen bien spécifique pour
commercialiser ses biens la vidéo quand
on rencontre nos clients revendeurs on
leur propose vraiment un package qui
requiert une vidéo un reportage photo et
dans cette vidéo la ce qui est très
important c'est qu'on travaille le coup
avec un photographe et vidéaste et c'est
vrai qu'il ya un impact tout de suite
sur les réseaux puisqu'on a déjà une
communauté d'acheteurs qui sont déjà
présents en fait sur ces sur ses plates
formes là un concept imaginé et
développé par cédric laporte gérant de
la société les réseaux sociaux pour nous
sont essentiels pour notre visibilité
pour notre communication pour créer du
lien également avec notre notre audience
nos grosses perfs réseaux sociaux c'est
vrai que ça permet beaucoup de choses ça
permet de montrer également son savoir
faire est également de par la vidéo le
savoir être également qui est très très
important dans les métiers de commerce
plusieurs formats sont proposés de la
présentation de biens au conseil en
immobilier en passant par des vidéos
plus légère du quotidien du personnel à
l'équipe l'équipe travaille l'équipe
travail de type plutôt café c'est pas
évident les premières vidéos c'est
difficile mais maintenant c'est pas
facile on a un retour de ça parce que
comme on est une agence locale moi les
gens nous identifier plus facilement
c'est plus facile pour rod nous
interpeller aussi quand on va faire la
prospection et donc voilà c'est toujours
sympa de pouvoir échanger avec les gens
du secteur grâce aux méthodes de
communication modernes cédric laporte
dirige l'entreprise depuis annecy être
conseiller immobilier est pour lui une
passion en plus d'une vocation c'est
pourquoi elle il ya deux ans il a lancé
un projet personnel destiné aux
professionnels du métier un moment donné
j'ai eu aussi cette envie là d'apporter
ma pierre à l'édifice à à l'immobilier
francophones en aidant d'autres agents
immobiliers à utiliser de bonnes
pratiques l'immobilier est pour moi bien
plus qu'un métier c'est une crampe
passion et cette passion j'aimerais
maintenant la partager avec toi je reste
très ciblée sur les professionnels de
l'immobilier je pense que c'est
important quand on veut réussir un
projet c'est d'être très spécifiques et
de ne pas partir dans tous les sens donc
déjà la chaîne youtube elle a pour
vocation toujours de former les
professionnels de l'immobilier
d'apporter du conseil des conseils qui
touche presque vingt mille conseillers
francophones et même suivi et repris par
ses collaborateurs tout de suite on
était en adéquation avec ce qu'ils
faisaient et en fait qui est vraiment
devenu une culture au sein d'entreprises
de prendre la ses conseils pour
justement nous aider aussi à
performer et puis aussi à nous ouvrir à
d'autres types d'outils on n'avait pas
l'habitude d'utiliser avant c'est vrai
que recevoir des messages quand je vois
que certains conseillers immobiliers ont
démarré en même temps que ma chaîne
youtube vers 2018 est aujourd'hui en
2021 2022 pardon ils ont ils ont atteint
les objectifs qui souhaitaient ils sont
heureux et épanouis dans leur métier
voilà je pense que ça c'est ma plus
grande ma plus grande récompense du
contenu réseau pour former qui ne
remplace pas le présentiel cédric la
porte se rend au moins une fois par
semestre dans son agence de villepreux
afin de faire un point et travailler
main dans la main avec ses
collaborateurs
[Musique]